good evening ladies and gentlemen and
thank you very much for coming out this
evening to this presentation by mr.
Frank McCourt just sponsored by pals
books with the assistance of Portland
Arts & Lectures before I introduce our
guests I'd like to draw your attention
to our monthly calendar of events at
pals books which you can find at the
store in the back of the church here
this evening the calendar of events will
give you information for all pals events
at all the PALS stores you can also find
the information on our website at
wwlp.com Whitehead in March Powell's
Books and Portland Arts & Lectures will
present an evening with authors Jim
Crais and roasts remain for further
information for Portland Arts & Lectures
they too have a website WWE dory arts
org tonight we're pleased to welcome mr.
Frank McCourt to Portland where he will
present his new memoir tis just
published by Scribner mr. McCourt burst
upon the literary scene in 1996 with
Angela's Ashes a rich autobiography that
appeared at a time when it seemed that
the art of memoir was at risk of
becoming a venue for wining and revenge
Angela's Ashes went on to win both the
National Book Award and the Pulitzer
Prize along with other notable citations
Mary Gordon called Angela's Ashes a
chronicle of surprising triumphs written
in a language that is always itself
triumphant now with tis mr. McCourt
recalls his passage back to America in
1949 and chronicles his life up until
the mid 80s when he makes an important
journey back to Ireland
Malcolm Jones of Newsweek wrote that it
is only the best storyteller who can so
beguile his readers that he leaves them
wanting more when he is done and the
court proves himself one of the best
twos has come to slake our thirst for
more after Angela's Ashes
but toward the end of tis one begins to
anticipate that thirst
once again this evening after the
reading mr. McCourt will answer some of
your questions following which we will
have a signing I would ask you to queue
up here the main aisle and it will be
serpentine so will be up this main aisle
around down this side aisle here around
up that aisle and if need be up the
stairs and into the balcony without
further ado please join me in welcoming
mr. Frank McCourt
was there nothing on television tonight
no no books to read at home I'm still
I'm still a bit odd when when I come and
do things like this and I look at a lot
of people sitting waiting to hear me
because I always think there's something
else going to come out somebody else
behind me that I meet that I'm I'm
introducing somebody I can't believe
that you're here for me because and you
look so respectful to because a it can't
in contrast to my years of teaching when
you went into a classroom and you had
depending on the class depending on the
school you had to struggle to get their
attention because generally where in my
case it was adolescence the high school
kids from New York City and you know
what you're dealing with when you're
dealing with high school kids you're
dealing with the most dangerous species
in the world the mystery but you know
what's going on - they're growing up
there they're masses of raging hormones
and at 16 and 17 they're always in love
and there's always a Jonathan in love
with the SUSE and over there and you
have to get their attention or one girl
in the class is paying no attention to
you whatsoever because she's looking
completely miserable she has a bias
spotted a zit on her chin and it's
ruined her looks so this that this is
the kind of audience that I had to deal
with most of my life so when I get
something like this I'm I'm in heaven
but but I expect I I had that uneasy
feeling something's going to happen the
one of you will rise and denounce me
just as my mother did that
my brother Malachy and I concocted a
show about growing up in Ireland the
coming to America call a couple of black
girls it's playing now and Boston if you
happen to be in Boston and we the first
night we put it on New York about 25
years ago she got up in the middle of
the first act and said announced the
audience wasn't that way at all it's all
a pack of lies that's the typical Irish
mother encouraging her son's to fame and
fortune so when I do this I know I know
I've written two books and I know
Angie's ashes was very successful beyond
my wildest expectations that they that
they printed 27,000 copies first edition
if you have one of those now it's it's
worth $650 I believe I'll take it off
your hands for 25 right and I didn't
expect this at all
nobody did and I'm often asked well how
do you how do you account for this the
success of that book and I don't know
because I'm a newcomer I just wrote one
book then a second one and people in the
business should know better than I there
are experts everywhere even in the
publishing business which seems to be a
big gambit because nobody expected
Angela's Ashes to go to have the success
it did that they printed that 27,000
copies in a couple of weeks it was on
the New York Times bestseller list at
number 15 the lowest number then it
began to climb till Tilly reach number
one and that took a that took a few
weeks
tis then was was published in September
and when it appeared on the bestseller
list the New York Times with number one
right up to number one
that's because mainly because of NGOs a
schism because I have some reputation
I'm a big shot now
and I had the best I want to have a
Pulitzer Prize and everything
the day after I won the Pulitzer Prize I
was saying to my wife we because I I'm a
good husband denied oh yeah I talked to
her the morning after I won the New York
they Pulitzer Prize I said to her well I
said how does it feel to have your head
in the same pillow as a Pulitzer Prize
winner I just
she said I'd feel much better if you get
up make the coffee because because I
always make the coffee oh I've always
meant but I thought because I won the
Pulitzer Prize I was excused for making
the coffee forever so I suppose I've had
to wait that I get the Nobel which would
be a cold day in hell that was a little
poem Nobel called day in hell so this is
this is this is the life I have no I I'm
talking about this because I'm still in
a state of surprise and puzzlement over
what has happened to me I know I wrote a
book I know they like that I know they
give me a Pulitzer Prize and then that
that people are buying this that that
Angela's Ashes first printing was 27,000
copies this was a million so you can say
I know Counting your fingers how much
I'm worth now that's what you're doing
so I have to do I have to deal with all
of this I have to deal with I have to
deal with what you might call Fame and I
suppose celebrity I'm a celebrity now I
know I'm a celebrity because people ask
me for my opinion on things what do you
think of the situation the north of
Ireland well what do I think of the
situation I'm very hopeful like
everybody else and then I get
invitations to write from various
magazines Gourmet magazine
they call they call me would you write
something for our magazine good I said
did you read Angela's Ashes
and then I get I get a call from one of
the glossiest magazines in the world
Architectural Digest would you like to
write something for us it's about what I
write about what we heard you just moved
and I could write about my move
yeah you know what you're right you know
what people always say when they move
well you never know what you have till
you move and I'm so glad to be able to
move I can get rid of all that junk
that's that's what you're right about so
this is the kind of thing and and I'm
I'm I'm invited to go and address
various organizations this is from some
kind of a dental organization teeth
orthodontist or something
dear mr. Colwyn we've we've know that
we've found 29 reference to teeth in
Angela's Ashes and we wonder if you come
and address our convention Boulder
Colorado and then a couple years ago I
was invited to for money to address the
New England Dental Association so I went
up to Boston and I was sitting in the
podium this huge ballroom fill mostly
women good-looking women of course
good-looking Yankee women and a few ogly
men and her and I said to the lady at my
side what's what's going on here is that
I didn't know there were so many female
dentists in New England are they all the
dancers at the owing than female it she
said well no she said actually she said
these are the wives of the dentist the
dentist's themselves are offers various
seminars and things keeping up with this
state of Dentistry and the wives have to
be entertained so we invited you
so I sank my teeth into that one oh gosh
I'm sorry and afterwards when I finished
signing books out in the lobby they they
they presented me with them with the big
box of toothbrushes more toothbrushes
than I could ever use in three lives and
then I say what no floss or would you
like a case of floss that's my life and
I go around ever since Angela Angela's
Ashes was probably I traveled I've been
traveling offered over three years and
what happened that what happened is I
have to get used to it the way I got
used to being a teacher it took me 15
years to be to feel comfortable in the
classroom I'm still not comfortable with
this particular giggling I'm on I like
to be home and I like to be ripe and I
like to walk the streets of New York and
I like I do get up in the morning make
the coffee for my wife Pulitzer Prize
are not Pulitzer Prize but you just wait
for the Nobel I but I just I still I I'm
getting used to this and I'm getting
what I like about it people are always
saying to me what we loved your book die
I go into stores and they stop me and
it's different from the high school days
when it was a struggle to get the kids
to listen to me any any high school
teacher knows it because you're dealing
with your döner with all the trauma of
adolescence they're always in love the
struggler home they worried about their
grades they're worried about their
appearance and you had to grab them and
you're competing with all kinds of
forces in the world
you're competing with the things I just
mentioned and you competing with
television you're competing with mules
you're competing walk rock music you're
competing with the internet you're
competing with the outside world in
general
and what can you say to the grab their
attention there are I suppose there are
two main ways of doing one threaten them
sit down Jonathan is shut up or you're
fail or Susan what do you think that
point means
you I know that you're really sensitive
soon and one thing you have to inveigle
them and try to get there and try to
seduce them in a way in a pedagogical
sense so so and what I what I discovered
in teaching there it wasn't that I had
to find my own way thrown into the
classroom nobody told me what to do
this is them I have a few passages here
about teaching that I'll get to in a
minute but what tis is about is my
learning how to be an American
growing up in Limerick in a place where
we essentially didn't know are some more
elbow about anything we didn't I come to
New York I didn't I am up food our food
was tea and bread maybe fish and chips
and occasional ham or a pig's head but a
lot of tea and and bread and I did we
didn't know anything we did when I
arrived in New York I didn't know
anything about the various fruits and
the abundance of fruits and vegetables
that you see in supermarkets and grocery
stores I knew nothing and we're also
when I arrived here I was a mess 19
years old badly infected eyes bad teeth
which were later which dentists later
walked on this first dentist I went to
in New York was about 92 years old he
was on 42nd Street and his name was
doctor of des on you and his hands
shocked at half the time the drill was
up my nostril
it terrified me he finally managed to
put on some porcelain caps which of
course
fell out very soon and they had to be
replaced with something I don't know
what what kind of material they use and
then then later on my eyes clear that
but I I had to find my way through New
York you don't know what it's like if
you grow up in this country you don't
know how complicated lending in New York
could be I didn't know the names of
things I I was walking in this hotel the
Biltmore Hotel near Grand Central
Station and I go out to lunch on 42nd
Street ahead in those days it was it was
a fairly rough Street in the head these
cafeterias would steam tables and I that
the first time I ever went into one of
these places and I stood in front of the
steam table and there are three women
behind and they're wearing white hats
and all that and there are people lined
up behind me it's lunchtime in New York
or people ruthless come on let's get go
let's go let's go let's go everybody's
in a big hurry they're usually from New
Jersey yeah
because New Yorkers are never in that
much of a hurry so I'm looking at all
this stuff - all this food laid out and
I pointed it so there's I'll have that
you want a hot dog I said yeah yeah hot
dog because I thought it was a sausage
okay and what do you want in your dog
and I looked I didn't know I didn't know
and I pointed it some other clock I said
she said you want gravy on your hot dog
and of course I turned red and I wanted
to go through the floor so and everybody
behind me was laughing then I said what
you're not supposed to have gravy and
your hot dog it might be delicious but
never ever again in public a suite
you're not there are certain things
you're not supposed to do in life
no glop gravy on your hot dog that's a
rule so then I had this job in the
Biltmore Hotel I was always the man I
know you've all been in hotels you've
sat in hotel lobbies you might have had
a drink there are people who go around
and clean up they take the glasses away
they take the napkins away they take the
swizzle sticks away I was one of those
people I would and I was in this lobby
the Biltmore Hotel which is often
mentioned that the stories of scott
Fitzgerald and John Cheever and then
on John Updike a gathering place the
prom court of the Biltmore Hotel for the
young men from the Ivy League Princeton
and Yale and Harvard and the girls from
Radcliffe and bring more ambassadors up
across the colleges and they would meet
there on Thursdays and Fridays that the
beautiful people that meet they're
looking for a date for the weekend
Thursdays and Fridays and I I am I
looked at them and there were my age 19
and 20 and 21 and there were the golden
people of America and I envied them
I was in a constant state of envy and
that's the same that's one of the seven
deadly sins so there it was doomed
already simply because severe I was
looking at these girls from the Ivy
League all these long-legged
Episcopalians with with that would me
all burn hair tumbling to their
shoulders that perfect milky white
shoulders the kind of piss Cup aliens
are known for and these bosoms that were
absolutely apocalyptic and I era and I
coveted them that's another sin so so is
it a Constance that just go wrong with
my dustpan of my broom sinning right and
left passively just pet it's the thought
that counts as I say because in
cathartic Catholicism they they're all
gradations of cinders the mortal sin
with sketches sent to hell sacrilege get
you're sent to hell
the venial sin sent get you sent to
purgatory for a few million years till
you wash away the sin and then there's
does the unforgivable sin we just asked
about that in school what is it nobody
knows well how do you know if you've
committed it you know I'm just
there's no priest in the world that can
forgive it you have to go on your to
Rome on your knees well we have we had
we asked it on does anybody know anybody
who committed the unforgivable sin well
we know a lot of people who want to
wrong but they took a flight or a
trainer that we we couldn't we spent
hours as kids trying to figure out what
the unforgivable sin was and then there
are the gradations of we were amateur
theologians I'm telling you that I'm
telling you this because this is the
baggage I carried with me the religious
baggage as well as the poverty baggage
that I carry to America with me there
are does a hierarchy of rewards and
Punishment if you're good and you follow
the rules of the Catholic Church opt you
go to heaven if you're in a state of
grace the soul is in here somewhere
it's wife and if that's we were told
this in there and if you commit a mortal
sin this abscess forms it's a dirty
filthy Posse thing that and it it drips
is and it eats away at the rest of the
white net and that's the market does it
the sacrilege to that's a bad one and
then if that's clean if you've been to
confession if you lead a good life and
you die you go to heaven if if if you're
bad you commit the mortal sin you go to
hell if you want to know what hell is
like regens Joyce's portrait of the
artist as a young man there's a couple
of sermons in there which will which
would drive you into the arms of the
priesthood then there's a another there
was another place that's purgatory of
course then there was another place
called limbo limbo is a place where
unbaptized babies go when they died and
we were all ascribe as always festively
with this limbo concept little
unbaptized babies or babies in foreign
countries like Africa or were never
baptized they all got to limbo
automatically and it's not their fault
that they were in baptized it does seem
to be some kind of injustice here and I
could never figure this out even as a
little kid as a why did little babies a
wild little baby is punished like this
and then in the 1960s the Vatican
Council about
as limbo I said well where the baby's
weight would did they automatically go
up to heaven it bothers me to this day
and I know the church comes up with the
satisfactory answer I'm not contributing
to the collection box anymore I want so
here I am at the Biltmore Hotel with all
of this stuff going through I still a
believer still full of guilt and sin in
everything else because when the church
gets you early they get the Jesuit say
give us a boy till he's seven he's ours
forever well they got me at about four I
think and I had such a sense of sin I've
never been able to get over the sense of
sin when I was teaching in New York in
the in the best high school New York
City Stuyvesant High School and we were
dealing with James Joyce was reading
Porter of the artists and then Ulysses
and I and I've sent to these kids and
we're looking at Stephen Dedalus as
tournement important of the artists and
then I realize this 16 year old kids 17
year old they didn't seem to have much
of a sense of sin then I said to them do
you know the seven deadly sins you don't
know the seven deadly sins until how the
hell can you enjoy yourself on
and I had to tell them the seven deadly
sins pride covetousness lost anger
gluttony envy and sloth
so I I believed all of this and when I
came to New York I was still in the
state of belief and guilt and remorse
and the rest of it and sinning all the
time passively because there wasn't much
chance of any action in the condition
yeah these are these Ivy League girls
were not exactly looking at me the girls
from Radcliffe and Bryn Mawr the wasn't
adoring me they were looking at all
these characters are these these broad
shoulder blue-eyed blonde guys from from
from the Ivy League all these
quarterbacks from Montana named Chuck so
and I had no self-esteem whatsoever so
I'm going around my dustpan and my broom
the bad days in the lobby are Thursday
and Friday when the boys and girls meet
and sit and drink and laugh nothing on
their minds but college and romance
sailing around in the summer skiing in
the winter and marrying each other so
they'll have children who'll come to the
Biltmore and do the same I know they
don't even see me in my husband's
uniform with my dustpan and broom and
I'm glad because there are days my eyes
are so red they look bloody and I dread
it when a girl might say excuse me where
is the restroom it's hard to point with
your dustpan and say over there beyond
the elevators when and keep your face
turned away at the same time they
shouldn't stare they should know better
the way their mothers and fathers are
spending fortunes to make them educated
and what's the use of all that education
if you saw ignorant you stare at people
just off the boat with red eyes you
think the professor's would be standing
in front of their classes telling them
that if you go to the Biltmore Hotel
lobby or any lobby you're not to be
staring at people with red eyes or one
leg or any class of a disfigurement the
girls stare anyway and the boys are
worse the way they look at me and smiled
and nudged past remarks that make
everyone laugh and I'd like to break my
dustpan and broom over their heads one
day there's a Yelp from a college girl
and the maitre d rushes over she's
crying and he's moving things around on
the table before her and looking under
at shaking his head he calls across the
lobby mccourt get over here right now
did you clean up around this table I
think I did you think you're dead
goddamnit excuse me miss don't you know
I did sir did you remove a paper napkin
I cleaned up I empty the ashtrays paper
napkin that was here did you take it I
don't know well let me tell you
something McCourt this young lady here
is the daughter of the President of the
traffic Club that rents a huge space in
this hotel and she had a paper napkin
with a phone number from a Princeton boy
if you don't find that piece of paper
your ass is in hot water excuse me miss
now what did you do with the trash you
took away
it's gone down to the big garbage bins
near the kitchen all right go down there
and search with that paper napkin don't
come back without it the girl who lost
the napkin sobs and tells me her father
has a lot of influence here and she
wouldn't want to be me if I don't find
that piece of paper
her friends are looking at me and I feel
my face is on fire with my eyes the
maitre d snaps at me again
go get it McCourt and report back here
the garbage bins by the kitchen are
overflowing and I don't know how I'm
going to find a small piece of paper
lost in all that waste coffee grounds
bits of toast
fish bones eggshells grapefruit skins
I'm on my knees poking and separating
with a fork from the kitchen where the
Puerto Ricans are singing and laughing
and banging in the pots and that makes
me wonder what I'm doing on my knees so
I get up and go into the kitchen saying
nothing to the Puerto Ricans calling to
me Frankie Frankie Irish boy we teach
you Spanish I find a clean paper napkin
right and made a phone number on it
stain it with coffee hand it to the
maitre d who hands it to the girl with
her friends cheering on all sides she
thanks the maitre d and passes him a tip
a whole dollar my only sorry is that it
won't be there when she calls that
number
so when you're in that condition I was
constantly putting my foot in it in New
York that's that's why until you until
you get to use to the ways of another
country this is something that happened
to me
that's simple I just want to go to the
movie and this movie night turned into a
disaster there's a poster outside the
68th Street Playhouse cinema that says
Hamlet with Laurence Olivier coming next
week I'm already planning to treat
myself to a night off with a bottle of
ginger ale and lemon and a lemon
meringue pie from the bakery there I be
watching Hamlet on the screen tormenting
himself and everybody else and I'll have
tartness of ginger ale and sweetness of
pie clashing away in my mouth before I
go to the cinema I could sit in my room
and read Hamlet to make sure I know what
they're saying in all that Old English
the only book I brought from Ireland is
the complete works of Shakespeare which
I bought in a manís bookshop for 13
shillings the last time I wanted the
68th Street Playhouse the usher wouldn't
let me in with the bar of Hershey's
chocolate in my hand he said I could not
bring in food or drink and I'd have to
consume it outside the 68th Street
Playhouse isn't a bit like the lyric
cinema in Limerick where you could bring
in fish and chips or a good feed at pigs
feet and a bottle of stout if the euro
was on you the night they wouldn't let
me in with the chocolate bar I had to
stand outside and gobble it with the
Oscar glaring at me and he didn't care
that I was missing funny parts of the
Marx Brothers now I have to carry my
black raincoat from Ireland over my arm
so the usher won't spot the bag with the
lemon meringue pie or the ginger ale
balls stuck in the pocket
the minute the film starts I tried to I
tried to go at my pie but the box
crackers and people say shush we're
trying to watch this film I know they're
not the ordinary type of people who got
to gang stir films and musicals these
are people who probably graduated from
college and live on Park Avenue and know
every line of Hamlet they'll never say
they got to movies only film
I'll never be able to open the box
silently and my mouth is watering with
the hunger and I don't know what to do
to the man sitting next to me says hi
slips part of his rank all over my lap
and lets his hand wander under it he
says am i disturbing you and i don't
know what to say that something tells me
take my pie and move away
I tell him excuse me and go buy him up
the aisle and out to the men's lavatory
what I'm able to open my pie box in
comfort without Park Avenue rushing me I
feel sorry over missing part of Hamlet
but all they were doing up there in the
screen was jumping around and shouting
about a ghost even though the men's
lavatory is empty I don't want to be
seen opening my box and eating my pie so
I sit on the toilet in the cubicle
eating quickly so that I can get back to
Hamlet as long as I don't have to sit
beside the man with the cordon in his
lap in the wandering hand the pie makes
my mouth dry and I think I'll have a
nice drink of ginger ale till I realize
you have to have some kind of open or to
lift off the cap there's no use going on
to inertia because they're always
barking and telling people they're not
supposed to be bringing in food or drink
from the outside even if they're from
Park Avenue I laid the pie box on the
floor and decide the only way to knock
the cap off the ginger ale bottle is to
place it against the sink and give it a
good rap with the back of my hand and
when I do the neck of the bottle breaks
and the ginger ale gushes up in my face
and there's blood in the sink where I
cut my hand at the bottom and I feel sad
with all the things happening to me that
my pie is being drawn on the floor with
blood and ginger ale and I'm wondering
at the same time will I ever be able to
see Hamlet with all the troubles I'm
having when a desperate looking
gray-haired man rushes in nearly
knocking me over and steps on my pie box
destroying it entirely he stands at the
urinal firing away trying to shake the
box of issue and barking at me god damn
what the hell he stands away and swings
his legs so the pie barks flies off his
shoe and hits the wall
all squashed and beyond eating the man
says what the hell is going on here
and I don't know what to tell him
because it seems like a long story
going all the way back to how excited I
was weeks ago about coming to see Hamlet
and how I didn't need all day because I
had a delicious feeling about doing
everything at the same time eating my
pie drinking ginger ale seeing ham
written and hearing all the glorious
speeches I don't think the man is in the
mood from the way from the way he dances
from one foot to the other telling me
the toilet is not a god damn restaurant
that I have no god damn business hanging
around public bathrooms eating and
drinking I'd better get my ass out of
that I tell him I had an accident trying
to open the ginger ale but he says did
you ever hear of an opener you just
upped the goddamn ball he leaves the
lavatory and just as I'm wrapping toilet
paper around my cot the ocean comes in
and says does the customer complaint
about my behavior in here
he's like the gray-haired man with his
goddamn and what the hell when I tried
to explain what happened he says get
your ass over here I tell him I pay to
see Hamlet and I came in here so it
wouldn't be disturbing all the Park
Avenue people around me who know Hamlet
backward and forward but he says I don't
give a [ __ ] get out before I call the
manager of the cops would surely be
interested in the blood all over the
place
then he points at my black raincoat
draped in the sink take that goddamn
raincoat over here what are you doing
with a raincoat in a day there ain't a
cloud in the sky we know the raincoat
trick and we're watching wait we know
the whole raincoat Brigade we're on to
your little queer games you sit there
looking innocent and the next thing the
hand is wandering over two innocent kids
so get your raincoat out of here buddy
before I call the cops you goddamn
pervert I take the broken ginger ale
bottle with the drop left to walk down
68th Street and sit in the steps of my
rooming house to my landlady mrs. Austin
cost with the basement window there's to
be no eating or drinking on the steps
cockroaches will come running from all
over and people would say we're a bunch
of Puerto Ricans who don't care where
they eat or drink or sleep there's no
place to sit anywhere along the street
with LAN ladies peering and watch
there's nothing to do but wander over to
a park where the East River and wonder
why America is so hard and complicated
that I have trouble going to see Hamlet
with a lemon meringue pie in about the
ginger ale
well I had that that job in the Biltmore
Hotel for about a year and a half then I
was liberated by the Chinese I want to
thank them further for Montse Tong for
sending his armies into North Korea
where we're upon America got nervous and
turned to me and drafted me and sent me
to Germany not to Korea in Germany I
spent two years in the k-9 Corps
training German Shepherd attack dogs
that was good preparation for my future
profession of teaching when I got out of
the army then I went to I went to NYU I
was I talked myself into NYU with no
high school education of diploma and
they said they admitted even admitted me
on probation for a year provided I
maintain a B average which I could have
done after lemis National School in
Limerick I think I'd have gone to
graduate school at Harvard because they
beat everything into us and so we could
forget nothing in Lee Me's when I got
out when I got out of the when I got my
degree in teaching I passed the exam for
I when I got my dear when I got my
degree at NYU I passed the license for
teaching then I had to look around for a
job my dream was to teach in a suburban
high school where there would be a lot
of these again long-legged Episcopalian
girls and and-and-and-and-and boys and
all they're all very clean in suburban
and upper-middle class and and they're
fascinated with me as I discourse most
eloquently on Chaucer and Shakespeare
the metaphysical of poets and they're
running home to their parents saying how
brilliant mr. McCourt well why don't we
invite him to dinner and and I'm invited
to all these mansions in Westchester and
South Hampton and scarcer and on Friday
nights and one Friday night I'm
introduced to this gorgeous young widow
and she's heir to an immense fortune as
she falls madly in love with me and she
says and we get married and she says
honey why don't you stay at home and
write but that didn't happen
everything 101 I went for the interviews
in the suburbs
they said the super administrators one
of they would say what's this I thought
what oh do I detect a foreign ism what
for
do I detect a Brogue oh yeah well I grew
up in Ireland oh well well I know you're
simply very intelligent we'd like to
have you but we really don't want our
children to come home sounding like
Barry Fitzgerald then I got this job in
McKee vocational high school in New York
I was told by everybody don't go near
vocational high school those kids are
killers
that show you up and spit you out the
movie or take em out just at that time
with the Blackboard Jungle if you have
time tonight go home and rent it Glen
Glen Ford knives and violence and
everything else and this is what I was
walking into in the middle of March
there's another notice in the paper of
vacancy at McKee vocational and
Technical High School for an English
teacher the assistant principal Missy
stead examines my license and takes me
to see the principal moses' Rolla
who doesn't move from his chair behind
the desk where he squints at me through
a cloud of smoke drifting from his nose
and from the cigarette in his hand he
says he says this is an emergency
situation the teacher I'd be replacing
miss Mudd has made an abrupt decision to
retire in the middle of the term he says
teachers like that are inconsiderate
make life hard for a principal he
doesn't have a full English program for
me that I'd have to teach three classes
and social studies every day two in
English but I don't know anything about
social studies he pops ssandsk Winston
says don't worry about it it takes me to
the office of the academic chairman who
says I'd be teaching three classes of
economic citizenship and here's the
textbook your world and you mr. Sorolla
smiles through the smoke and says you're
warned than you that should cover just
about everything
I tell him I know nothing about
economics or citizenship and he says
just a few pages ahead of the kids
everything you tell them will be news
tell them this is 1958 tell them their
names
tell them they live on Staten Island and
they'll be surprised and grateful for
the information by the end of the year
even your name will be news to them
forget your college literature courses
this is not high IQ Plateau
he takes me to see miss mud the teacher
I'd be replacing when he opens the
classroom door boys and girls are
leaning out the windows calling to
others across the schoolyard miss Mudd
sits at her desk reading travel
brochures ignoring the paper airplane
that zooms over her head
miss mud has retired mr. Sorolla leaves
the room as she says that's right young
man I can't wait to get out of here
what's this Wednesday Friday is my last
day and you're welcome to this loony bin
32 years I've been at this and who cares
kids parents who young man gives a [ __ ]
forgive my French we teach their brats
and they pay us like dishwashers what
was the year 19 and 26 Calvin Coolidge
was in I came in I worked right through
him and the depression man Hoover and
Roosevelt and Truman and Eisenhower look
out that window you got a good view of
New York Harbor from here a Monday
morning if these kids aren't driving you
crazy you'll see a big ship sailing by
and that'd be me on the deck waving son
waving and smiling because there's two
things I never want to see again in my
life with God's help Staten Island and
kids monsters look at them you'll be
better off working with chimpanzees in
the Bronx Zoo what's this nineteen and
fifty-eight how did I ever last you'd
need to be Joe Lewis so good luck son
you're going to need it No
I took that job I had serious doubts if
I if I could handle it but I'm I had to
travel from Manhattan off the Staten
Island under ferry some of you have been
on that ferry but it's two weeks into
the job III thought quit him because it
was so hard in any other profession you
can hide you can't hide when you're
teaching you go in there in the morning
you might not you might have had a fight
with your wife you might have a hangover
you might have the flu but there's no
escaping they're looking at you five
classes a day five days a week these
adolescents and they're looking at you
and they're looking for some weakness in
your system the like heat-seeking
missiles and you have to have the energy
to deal with them and their energy is
enormous and you have maybe 160 kids and
the sucking the energy out of you and
you have to keep up then you have to
know the tricks and it takes a long time
to be able you have to develop your own
style I went in like an Irish
schoolmaster Theo I thought it was going
to dominate them all no you'll teach
what you're talking like that huh
because some of these kids weren't the
only McKee football team they could have
broken me into so I had serious doubts
the first day I went into the classroom
they were Here I am after four years of
college education I walk into this
classroom they're not in their seats
they're hanging out the wind the car
into the kid friends across the way the
girls are putting on makeup boys us
wrestling two of them on the throwing
sandwiches of each other
and after four years of education the
first words out of my mouth as a teacher
are stop throwing sandwiches
years of literature and these this is
what I was this is what what this is a
kind of a that this was the atmosphere
of a classroom is this what I'll do the
rest of my life take the sub within the
ferry to Staten Island climb the hill to
McKee vocational high school punch in at
the time clock extract the Bulge of
paper from my mailbox tell my students
class after class day after day
sit down please open your notebooks take
out your pens you don't have paper
here's paper you don't have a pen borrow
one copy the notes in the board you
can't see from there joy would you
change seats with Brian come on Joey
don't be such a no joy I didn't call you
a jerk I just asked you to change seats
with Brian who needs glasses
you don't need less as Brian well why do
you have to move never mind joy just
move will you Freddy
put that sandwich away this isn't a
lunchroom I don't care if you're hungry
no you can't go to the bathroom to eat
your sandwich you're not supposed to be
eating sandwiches in the toilet what is
it Maria you're sick you have to see the
nurse Maria okay here's a pass Diane
would you take Maria to the nurse's
office and let me know what the nurse
says no I know they won't tell you
what's wrong with her I just want to
know if she'll be coming back to class
what is it Albert you're sick too no
you're not however you just sit there
and do your work you got to see the
nurse out but you're really sick you
have diarrhea
well here here's the pass of the boys or
we don't stay they're all period the
rest of you finish copying the notes on
the board there will be a test you know
that don't you there will be a test
what's that Sebastian your pen ran out
of ink well why didn't you say something
yes you're saying it now but you could
have said it 10 minutes ago all you
didn't want to interrupt all these sick
people
that's that's nice of your Sebastian
does anyone have a painter loan
Sebastian oh come on what's that joy
Sebastian is a watt or what you
shouldn't say things like that joy
Sebastian sit down no fighting in the
classroom what's that and you got to go
go where I know you got you got your
period you're right joy she doesn't have
to tell the whole world yes yes Daniela
you want to take end to the bathroom why
all she don't I she doesn't speak good
English
so what does this have to do with her
having what's that Joey you don't think
girls should talk like that
easy Daniela easy you don't have to be
insulting what's that joy you're
religious and people shouldn't talk like
that okay easy Daniela I know you're
defending and who needs to go to the
toilet the bathrooms of gold take her
there and the rest of you copy the notes
on the board or you can't see either you
want to move up okay move up here's an
empty seat well where's your notebook
you left it on the bus all right you
need paper here's paper you need a pen
here's a pen
you need to go to the bathroom we'll go
to the bathroom eat a sandwich hang out
with your friends Jesus mr. McCoy
McCourt you since way like that Yuson
said god's name like that
and finally since it's the holiday
season have a it's the story of my first
Christmas in New York after I got out of
the army when I got a room in a boarding
house my new landlady is mrs. Agnes
Klein and she shows me a room for $12 a
week I'm hardly in the door when mrs.
Klein is telling me her history she
tells me I'm not to jump to any
conclusions her name might be Klein but
that was her husband who was Jewish her
own name is Kent E and I should know
very well you can't get more Irish than
that and if I have no place to go at
Christmas I can spend it with her and
her son Michael what's left of him her
husband Eddie was the cause of all her
troubles just before the war he ran off
to Germany with their four-year-old son
Michael because his mother Eddie's
mother was dying and he expected to
inherit her fortune of course they were
rounded up the whole tribe of Klein's
mother and all and then they're up in a
camp no use telling the damn Nazis
Michael was an American citizen born in
Washington Heights the husband was never
seen again but Michael survived and at
the end of the war the poor kid was able
to tell the Americans who he was she
tells me what's left of him is in a
little room down the hall she says I
should come to her kitchen Christmas Day
about 2:00 in the afternoon and have a
little drink before dinner
there won't be Turkey she'd like to cook
European if I don't mind she tells me
don't say yes unless I mean it that I
don't have to come for Christmas dinner
if I have someplace to go
some Irish girl making mashed potatoes
don't worry about her it wouldn't be her
first Christmas with no one but Michael
at the end of the hall what's left of
him
on Christmas Day there are strange
smells from the kitchen and there's mrs.
Klein pushing things around in a frying
pan pierogi she says polish Michel of
them have a vodka with a little orange
juice good for you this time of the year
with the flu coming on we sit in our
living room with our drinks and she
talks about her husband she says we
wouldn't be sitting around drinking
vodka and cooking up the old pierogi if
he were here for him
Christmas was business as usual she
leans over to adjust the light in her
wig falls off and the vodka in me makes
me laugh out loud at the sight of her
skull with little Tufts of brown hair
go ahead she says someday your mother's
wig will fall off and we see if you're
laughed then and she caps the wig back
in her head I tell him my mother has a
fine head of hair and she says no wonder
your mother never had a lunatic husband
that walked into the arms of the Nazis
for Christ's sakes if it wasn't for him
mica what's left of him would be out of
that bed they're having a vodka with his
poor mouth warning for his pierogi oh my
god the pierogi she jumps from her chair
and runs to the kitchen what a little
there little burn but that only makes
them nice and crisp my philosophy is do
you want to know my philosophy is
whatever goes against you in the kitchen
you can turn to your advantage we might
as well have another vodka while I cook
the sauerkraut and kielbasa she pours
the drinks and barks at me when I asked
her what kielbasa is she says she can't
believe the ignorance in the world two
years in the United States Army and you
don't know from kielbasa
no wonder the Communists are taking over
its polish for Christ's sake sausage and
you should watch me fry it in case you
marry someone who's not Irish a nice
girl who might demand her kielbasa we
stay in the kitchen with another vodka
well the kielbasa sizzles and the
sauerkraut's Jews with the vinegar smell
mrs. Klein puts three plates on a tray
and pours a glass of Manischewitz wine
from mica what's left of him he like he
loves it she says love
the Manischewitz with the pierogi and
kielbasa I follow her through her
bedroom into a small dark room were
Michael what's left of him sits up in
the bed staring ahead we bring in chairs
and use his bed as a table mrs. Klein
turns on the radio and we listen to
umpah Oompa accordion music that's his
favorite music she says anything
European he gets nostalgic you know
nostalgic for Europe for Christ's sakes
don't you Michael
don't you I'm talking to you Michael
Merry Christmas Michael merry god damn
Christmas she tears off her wig and
throws it into a corner no more
pretending Michael I've had it talk to
me on next year I cook American next
year the turkey Michael the stuffing the
cranberry sauce though works Michael he
stares straight ahead in the kielbasa
grease glistens around his plate his
mother fiddles with the radio that she
finds Bing Crosby singing white
Christmas better get used to it Michael
next year being in the stuffing
to hell with kielbasa she pushes her
plate her side on the bed and falls
asleep with her head by Michaels elbow I
wait a while take my dinner to the
kitchen dump it into the garbage return
to my room and fall into my own bed
thank you
thank you
I have some questions or two what advice
would you give unmotivated students
today well it depends on the I think it
depends on the situation the school
family background on the rest of it
the alternative to failing in school
the alternative to succeeding is banned
what happens to you then I used to say I
I used to say to my students at Makia
vocational high school if you don't pay
attention you'll fail you won't pass
this course if you don't pass this
course you won't graduate from high
school and if you don't graduate from
high school who will go out with you
good bet that was amazing thank thank
thank God to them they look they looked
around I know no questions were asked
later on the school would you go out
with me Miriam if I fail and that kind
of and today the second question on this
sheet is what are you reading there what
I just finished reading a fantastic
novel called birdsong by Sebastian Boggs
about World War one would life in the
trenches of World War and Anniston
current of parallel love story I read it
in I read it I was quite flying from
Amsterdam to San Francisco the other day
and I think I read that book in one
sitting I couldn't put it down
next one what made you decide to be a
teacher did you have an epiphany or was
it a gradual process
it was a gradual process because I I i
looked around that the other things that
I didn't think I was capable of doing
much in the USA I died I died I was
offered a job in a bank but
manufacturers trust company but I didn't
see myself going into an office every
day and wearing a suit and carrying a
briefcase I would have died I would have
been looking at the clock because I took
a few of those temporary office jobs
from a company called mentor and i sat
there tight I thought I would expire I
didn't know how people could go into
officers day after day and then I
combined my my affection for kids and my
love of literature that was it of course
you become a teacher and you don't have
much status in this society you know
that you like the downstairs maid you're
told when you when you come to
somebody's house go in the back door
you're only a teacher engineers and
lawyers and so on can come in the front
door and priests but what quietly but
not teachers and teacher that the loss
of the lowest-paid of all the so-called
professions if a teacher if teaches us
for a raise we say well what do you need
more money you want more Mundell all the
time off you have well take 160 kids
assign an essay of 200 to 150 words long
take those papers home on a weekend
there goes your weekend you could have
been reading war and peace or something
like that and you have this bag of paper
they have to be read sometime they have
to be corrected you don't get any time
off as an English teacher particularly
you're always on the job no matter what
you read no matter what you see you
think I can use that in the classroom
well you and I know I know there are
there are moments in families where your
son or your daughter has announces that
he or she is going to be a teacher and
your face drops you ain't going to be
driving no BMW
what has this next quarter what have the
Irish said about your book what is
number one in Ireland Angela's Ashes was
still on the bestseller list after two
and a half years and teases number one
and that they shot the movie there most
of them all of the movie Avengers asses
were shot and they turned out they did
seven thousand auditions in Dublin
Limerick and court do you ever think
about what your life would have been
like had your parents not returned to
Ireland yet they still would have stayed
in Brooklyn I would have been a Dodger
fan I would I would have consumed
Budweiser I'd be fat as a full known as
the first time author do you struggle
with editors over style and punctuation
issues was it hard to convince them not
to include quotation marks no I didn't
have any trouble because Angela's Ashes
has written for the point of view of a
child now and I thought children don't
struggle with quotation marks oh I just
eliminated them and it seemed more
direct it seemed easier it seems simpler
it seemed clear and it seemed to work as
long you don't get as long as the reader
doesn't get confused between one
sentence and the next one so I think
Alya and anyway I have to look up the
history of the quotation mark I don't
think it's been around very long some
fool brought it around 1890 or something
like that quote a punctuation is of
recent origin if you look at some
medieval manuscripts they just flow
wonderful from one word to the other
they don't even have a period or as I
say then a fourth stop did you ever find
the priest worthy of hearing your
confession
my mother used to said to me sometimes
when I when I joke around about the
church she said to me you'll be calling
for a priest on your deathbed
I said no nothing less than an
archbishop
I found prays that a priesthood I don't
think any priest that I know worthy
who'd want to hear my confession
probably wouldn't want to hear it they
can give you something I called general
absolution the old days you had to
listen and detail all your sins now you
just say I'm sorry then in the churches
I know I was in a church and I think in
Florida area of someplace recently and I
know in inside the lobby this I've
always gone around the charts it they
don't have them here of course there's
been a Protestant place could fashion
the confession boxes are big difícil
if the church I used to go to in
Limerick had 13 in the pretentious
Church you go when you sit down presa
there and little penance lies back and
you tell your sins and all the deadly
sins of commit and so and then he gives
you it gives you a penance that he gives
you up look that's all gone now
the great sense of drama is gone now
they're going to something called the
reconciliation rule it's like on to
therapy it doesn't have the threat
anymore so in what way did you did your
own background in poverty affect your
interaction with students who were also
from poverty background that that's a
good question because I think I
understood when I was teaching the Lower
East Side of Manhattan whether were all
kinds of that was a kind of ethnic
melting pot Chinese kids Porto Rican
kids Cubans Dominicans and black kids
there was a lot of poverty down there
and at first I didn't understand what
was going on they would erupt basically
erupt in rage and yell and carry on and
I used to take it personally then I
realized that's the way I was myself
that's the rage that I had myself and I
think once I made that breakthrough that
understanding it helped me become I hope
a more effective teacher who is the
Irish author you respect most it's not
made [ __ ]
it's
although I like a naturally that they
the quest the answer to that is is James
Joyce he's the man he's the main man we
see the I James Joyce never received a
Nobel Prize Yates did Seamus Heaney did
George Bernard Shaw Samuel Beckett I
think the Irish have received more Nobel
prizes in literature than the people who
impose the language on us the English so
I just have to I said running through
Angela's Ashes and tis because there's
one theme that has to do with my mother
and I just want to tell you one story
about my mother how disappointed she was
in us her four sons I think she was
disappointed anyway because she said one
woman one friend said to her mrs. McCoy
you must be so proud of your four fine
sons if he's a proud is it proud every
one of them is a crucifixion to me and
and she complained that she I think she
wanted one of us to marry a nice Irish
Catholic girl something so that she'd
having something in common with them
that they could go to bingo together and
got to church together and talk about
eternal things me well she said she
complained there's nothing in this
family but Jews and Protestants
Protestants and Jews every time I cross
the floor I'm tripping over little Jews
or Protestants
and then the kids would come running dad
what was Nana doing to me in the middle
of the night pouring water all over my
head
she'd baptize anything the goldfish
wasn't safe in the ball and then the
area that she lived in in Manhattan up
at the Upper West Side was it was at
large it had many many Jewish families
and young Jewish coppers would like my
mother and they that asked her to
babysit on a Saturday night and she
called and baby said she was very benign
very maternal and that she'd go out to
take care of the baby and a minute the
young George got so so the lot of young
Jewish people wandering around New York
who think they're Jewish but they belted
the Vatican thank you